[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est aux histoires vraies je vous jure
le meilleur moment et et le moment le
pire de ma vie c'est quand j'étais au
milieu escaliers j'ai entendu c'est à
dire vraiment il donc là est la même et
elle a hurlé quoi selimi mais sa passe
est lucho ta voiture sur le périph vous
savez les belles histoires
oui cette égalisation voilà à desquels
station alors c'était je pense à rien je
crois que c'était megapot mère non non
non c'est rien je crois que c'était une
vague dance baltes au manitoba les trois
vallées bah je peux vous dire que les
avaler les ont vus ces chirurgies non en
fait alors hier soir on recevait laurent
baffie et je vous dit tout je suis resté
poli bon c'est l'heure de manger c'est
bien mais tu manges à quelle heure
rappelle qu'il est neuf heures chez moi
moi j'ai à 19 heures moi je mange pas je
suis avec vous je peux pas m'en la t2a
les garçons n'ont reçu laurent baffie
rappelé dont c'est le meilleur sniper en
activité après valérie benaïm bien sûr
ça là c'est une kangoo reçoit fils est
très content ouais et vous êtes contents
mais on sent quand même vous êtes
toujours sur le qui vive a bien su alors
est un peu loin et je veux faire un
petit résumé de sa venue et bien sûr le
50 secondes inside au j'adore
[Musique]
vous avez pris vos précautions par
rapport au csa laurent baffie peut
désormais sur scène et vannes qui veut
mais il était plutôt sage avec les
chroniqueurs quand même été déposé
absolument
mais quand vous avez non je vous jure
vous avez disputé toute la journée vous
pensé à tout sauf à la blague est bonne
et on met en cause
on a fait les implants même ténue il est
intéressé salaire normal aussi ma fille
voulait voir si son livre de définition
était aussi marrant quand il est élu par
les chroniqueurs et maintenant je crois
qu'il connaît la réponse en béton qui
tueraient père et mère pour avoir une
famille après ce naufrage td a voulu
sauver le navire bien sûr alors laxatifs
produit qui permet au sel de courir plus
vite que les chevaux c'est vrai que
c'est mal vu alors que quand ma fille
vit lui-même sa définition c'est un peu
de chose quand même
michel mr toujours en ballotage 3 10e
quand mes couilles
et donc une des spécialités de laurent
baffie ce sont les blagues alors
matthieu delormeau il a voulu tester son
humour faso m vous allez voir c'est un
immense succès oui georges était un
exemple de blogs chrétiens est baby j'en
ai triste parce qu'en deux poissons
s'engueulent le ton monte
il a toujours l était pas si mauvaise
voiture
je n'ai pas couru pique la vedette à la
la il faut pas exagérer non plus voilà
près exagérer non plus jamais alors x
men vous avait dévoilé le rapprochement
entre deux personnes dans sur son
plateau puisque vous savoir faire qui
déjà n'ont volé even haïm
ah oui avec et cyril hanouna oui bien
sûr lancé deux personnes n'avaient ni
force forcément vous aimez le plus ici
vous devez la vérité apatow ça suffit
pas naïve alors non non non non mais
c'est mon frère
bon vous café continue enquête décidée
au tournoi franchement c'est un peu
compliqué parce que j'ai très peur que
la merguez était trempée dans la harissa
bravo je sais pas ça vous de me dire
j'ai les images devant elle parle des
mêmes vous pouvez plus vous cacher
désormais c'est la suite des aventures
de valeur et baba c'est quoi ce qui
selon antisismiques
[Musique]
comment va le vous traîtres série je
suis sûr que c'est le comportement d'une
femme blessée qui veut se venger
je le dis et pour tout le monde et ça
sera la règle dans mon jeu on peut
chambrer a le droit de souffler des
collectes dans les règles de l'art donc
je reformule on a le droit d'être un
petit [ __ ]
eh bien je crois qu'on se profile jeu
dans cette finale tant attendue
la revanche de la revanche de la
revanche une finale de connard benjamin
versus avec les angels ou serait tombé à
toujours respecter vos questions à deux
points ça c'est facile pour vous bon
franchement cyril ça si vous
correspondez pas vous êtes un connard je
vais me faire traiter toutes les niches
j'aimais pour valérie benaïm cyril vous
êtes un petit [ __ ]
vous êtes un connard alors depuis si
elle vous fait tout pour vous faire
pardonner vous utilisez les stratagèmes
et plus romantiques et les plus
érotiques
le président du prg est stable ouais
merci d'être avec nous cette gloire on a
et on dirait bien là des lilas regardez
là bas c'est tout le maghreb en écoutant
non plus très excitante comme ça alors
les châteaux la norme et pénales je suis
est magnifique oui mais nadine cette
coiffure mais gare à dire assez bien
fait alors ah non mais ce carré
plongeant sans rigoler on dirait laure
manaudou
non mais je te jure que c'est vrai et
puis j'adore hamar devant devant opposer
l'armée mais là on dit que dans le pré
vous leur tournée non mais c'est vous
que je vais retourner vous voulez donc
retourné valérie benaïm alors pour la
convaincre vous sortez votre dernière
carte votre imitation du plombier de
pézenas je vais te répondre de façon
sexy bancaire est encore contre moi
pourtant quand au top
bonjour j'ai rendez vous avec le médecin
ce week-end mais de ses six rendez vous
avec le docteur en ville à drew vous
savez que c'est à nos docteurs aux
méthodes peu orthodoxes
[Rires]
j'adore ces films érotiques un film de
jean pas bien si ce bad m6 web augmenter
un petit peu ça défile je regardais les
films érotiques du divorce la nuit c'est
le problème c'est que non c'est sur tf1
attention attention aux appels pendant
le film érotique de m6 il y avait un
truc qui te tue et stx et ça c'est
magnifique alors spécialise de films
érotiques tout a bien sûr jean michel
tomasek d'amis qui voue un véritable
culte si c'est vrai c'est un petit peu
le style ce qu'il aurait voulu avoir
germain oui mais moi je sais un petit
peu mon grand frère et jean-marc léger a
marqué ce alors il sait que sans vous il
serait aujourd'hui en reportage en
italie en plein coeur du corona des rues
font alors grâce à vous il est payé pour
regarder la télé sortir des vannes et en
plus il a la chance de pouvoir fayoter
d'être payé pour ça la preuve dont c'est
le retour bien sûr comme chaque mois du
fatah
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
on a vu des numéros dans la france a un
incroyable talent de l'ammoniac celui ci
j'étais animateur en club de vacances et
voulait mettre gens responsables
aquatique je vous dis arrêtez c'est pas
ma spécialité c'est pas qu'on laissait
la bouche les selles
laura bush laura flessel c'est excellent
je voulais dire que vous êtes un très
bon animateur je trouve que rien encore
meilleurs chroniqueurs qu'elle inspire
ce petit reprise mais nous nous parlait
pas anglais sérieuse ou pas ce gars un
supermarché à lille et oui à lille
[Musique]
alès il est bon ça paie et
elle
pour garder surtout stress
[Musique]
avec chaque semaine je vous montre les
images chocs away de l'art de la
rébellion et chroniqueurs font tous
leurs patrons cyril hanouna
il est temps de regarder le bâclage
backlash 3 aux bananes laroiseau au
petit déjeuner il ya des rayons petit
déjeuner c'est bien sûr des bruits mais
c'est pas que c'est pas chez lidl chez
lidl pas si les dix d'arracher le nul
chez le notaire est synonyme d'un gamin
tout ok mais avouez que c'est pénible
c'est le problème il est là c'est que
les loyers sont devenus complètement
dingue et les gens qui souffrent
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils ont eu
800 900 balle de loyer donc tu peux pas
y arriver comme si j'étais vous fais le
serment vous intégrez vous
financièrement vous êtes inquiet du coup
pas quelle chaîne se trouve sur le canal
19 de la tnt une réponse de kelly dans
les frères parce que toi tu es chômeuse
[Rires]
dégoûté parce que je le savais pas vous
c'est tout bête mais doit traiter plein
de fois tu peux voir c'est vanessa
amical est ce que je le prends très bien
classé mais qu'elles n'ont pas montré de
ce qu'on veut bien sûr gros cons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va se retrouver dans la brèche night
bolloc'h